dans toujours ici aux appareils déjà
l'arrivée de ce convoi humanitaire qui
était censé arriver hier en milieu
d'après midi
beaucoup de flou entoure justement
d'arriver le nombre de personnes qu'il
s'agit à deux femmes et d'enfants
uniquement ou s'il y aura des hommes à
bord de ce convoi humanitaire
jusqu'à cette heure donc nous trouvons
ici dans ce parking qui a été transformé
en centre d'accueil et qui est censé
recevoir ce convoi humanitaire alors les
personnes qui se trouvent ici il ya
beaucoup de volontaires mais il ya aussi
des ong internationales et locales un
dispositif donc qui est mise en place
pour accueillir au mieux toutes ces
personnes qui ont vécu l'enfer de
marioupol donc on leur donne de quoi
boire et manger mais il ya aussi tout un
suivi psychologique avec la présence de
beaucoup de psychologues qui sont ici
justement donc pour accueillir toutes
ces personnes qui ont vécu des semaines
extrêmement difficile donc pour l'heure
un peu d'info qui circulent mais on
attend toujours l'arrivée qui devrait en
principe se faire aujourd'hui est un bon
jour tarek voulez vous avez vu ses
habitants de marioupol qu'ils viennent
de vivre l'enfer arriver jusqu'à vous
jusqu'à zaporizhya parfois par leurs
propres moyens à bord de leur voiture
ils vous ont raconté ce qu'ils ont vécu
dit tout ce qu'ils vous ont dit
tout à fait donc il s'agit surtout de
gens de citoyens de marioupol qui ont
profité de cette trêve du cessez-le-feu
pour emprunter ces routes sortir des
territoires qui sont sous l'occupation
russe et partir dans ces territoires
sous contrôle de l'armée craignait donc
il s'agit pas des citoyens qui sont
sortis d'azov talent mais plutôt de la
ville de marioupol mais également des
villages autour qui sont sous
l'occupation
russe alors les témoignages que nous
avons recueillis sont extrêmement forts
ces personnes nous ont pas les toutes
les difficultés qu'ils ont vécu une
personne nous a dit qu'il a vécu pendant
un mois dans sa cave il nous a parlé des
corps qui se trouvent dans les rues
certains corps qui ont été enterrés un
demi mètre de profondeur très rapidement
en attendant d'être enterré plus tard
plus dignement ils nous ont parlé des
difficultés de pouvoir se nourrir à
boire des fois ils ont été obligés
de de faire bouillir l'eau ou même de
faire fondre la glace une dame nous a
parlé des bombardements qui ont atteint
son immeuble dès les premiers jours du
conflit elle nous a également parlé de
sa grande joie quand elle a vu les
soldats ukrainien et quand elle a appris
qu'elle était en sécurité et en
territoire sous contrôle du kenya